the company that we talked about where
we said oh we met this girl she was a
college student at NYU they got they did
that Clubhouse thing where they did
shoot your shot and I met her and I was
like wow you're a star I don't know what
this idea is she was doing like some web
3 version of The Bachelor I was like oh
that's a terrible idea but this is hey
that's okay this is your terrible idea
you're gonna do amazing things I think
they might have already pivoted into
something kind of amazing or found
something amazing under their umbrella
and it's these shows so the watch one
has in in four weeks 14 million views 2
million likes and a total budget of I
think two thousand dollars 100 190 000
followers
[Music]
foreign we're live brother it's been dry
for me not a lot of research and ideas
going on are you the same dry season
it's dry season
yeah I um
I know what you mean but
um I can't say I relate because your
boy's wet really you have stuff Andre's
dripping with Concepts you know actually
I have all the stuff prepared and then
like
typically in the four hours before we
record
I just come up with a whole different
set of things that I want to talk about
the first one
is okay so
I don't know the full back story of this
but I I do think it's kind of cool so I
saw a tweet that basically said there's
like five 21 year olds who are building
you know some Next Generation Media
company uh okay what are you guys doing
well basically it took him one month and
they launched a series of original Tick
Tock shows so not just like themselves
on Tick Tock but an actual show so
there's one show called buying time it's
where they buy and sell watches like
kind of like on the Fly
um and you get to see them like buy or
sell negotiate the watch what's the name
of the company so the name of the
company what is their name
um
I thought it was related to that mad
realities thing it might be it's gonna
say it sounds like that
I think it is related to them I'll I'll
try to try to go find it yeah it is it's
either produced by them it's theirs or
they're like in the network I'm not sure
but they're in in their bio for all the
shows it's at mad realities right so
that the brand that we the the company
that we talked about where we said oh we
met this girl she was a college student
at NYU they got they did that Clubhouse
thing where they did shoot your shot and
I met her and I was like wow you're a
star I don't know what this idea is she
was doing like some web 3 version of The
Bachelor I was like oh that's a terrible
idea but this is hey that's okay this is
your terrible idea you're gonna do
amazing things I think they might have
already pivoted into something kind of
amazing or found something amazing under
their umbrella and it's these shows so
the watch one has in in four weeks 14
million views two million likes and a
total budget of I think two thousand
dollars 190
000 followers and what are they doing on
the show and does that two by the way
some of these numbers might be a little
off we we got we got Brandon the
researcher he's running on the hamster
wheel in the back here he's trying to
get all the data but sometimes I mess up
kind of reading his data so so numbers
are directional for anything I ever say
okay
um but I did watch this other one keep
the meter running so keep reader
running's cool you'll like this concept
they get in a cab in New York and
the guy's like all right where are you
trying to go and he's like uh where do
you like to go in New York why don't you
take me there
I've seen this it's so good he's like
take me to your favorite favorite place
you know let's go eat uh you want lunch
have you eaten today and the guy's like
no I I don't need to end of my shift
he's like let's go take me to your
favorite spot he's like okay he's again
just keep the meter running and they
basically drive to like you know the
little the like Halal Town part of New
York to get out and you hear this story
he's like he's like leave the meter
running they go inside they eat he asks
them about his kids and his life and how
he ended up with a taxi does he like it
and they're just enjoying a meal and
they just do that the whole day uh also
2.4 million likes 160 000 followers
budget it's really really great man
that's a really great have you seen it
I've seen it it's like um if humans of
New York was a tick tock show and um and
so they definitely find some gems of
like human beings and you're just like
by the end of it you're just like I just
love this dude I just want this like
taxi driver to have an easier life and
it's a great show she's happy too which
is the best part it's not it doesn't
make you feel guilty because they're sad
they're very happy and content with a
simple life and most of the people who
are watching Tick Tock have like 10
times more going for them than this guy
and are 10 times less happy and you know
discontent of scrolling Tick Tock
basically at the time so it's like one
of those things that makes you feel good
it's a feel-good show then they have
this other one called Einstein
Elementary it's basically this guy
he calls himself the Einstein of Wall
Street it kind of looks like Einstein
got gray hair puffing out to the side
and he just explains stock market [__]
in like simple terms and this one has a
million likes and a hundred thousand
followers and I'm just like this is
really really cool they are basically
prototyping these shows that could be
produced into real shows or this might
be it
um and the reason I wanted to bring this
up
is because
a 21 year olds doing cool [__] love it B
if you think about like what's the next
Generation like you know you worked on
that show or worked with a guy from
American Pickers or like there's all
these like random Niche shows right it's
like yeah these guys they go into
[__] storage units and they like you
know they have to cook a meal out of
what's in there yeah who the [__] out of
this why am I watching this for two two
and a half hours
um
those shows are going to happen on tick
tock not TV and they're gonna happen
like a thousand fold you're gonna get a
thousand times more experiments just
using Tick Tock the second thing is I
have this framework that I learned from
it by Buddy Sully which was the doors
versus Windows so when I saw this I was
like huh they got like you know millions
of views
but they kind of don't make any money
and it kind of goes away so I don't
really see the opportunity
and at first I kind of wrote it off like
yeah that's the problem with Tick Tock
man you can get you can pop off but like
then what so what and I think that's so
what drives away a lot of people
but there's another part of me that's
like
of course this is valuable of course if
you created a show that people like and
millions of people watch it there's
going to be value there on this platform
that's growing and taking over like the
entire social media it's like the
fastest growing company in the world uh
of course you being one of the fastest
growing channels on the fastest growing
up you know media app is a is a very
valuable thing it's just not clear
exactly what that value is how you'll
capture it and in a few years it'll be
like wow this person makes a hundred
million dollars off Tick Tock that's
crazy right the same way we say about Mr
Beast on YouTube and people on Twitch oh
ninja makes how many millions of dollars
on Twitch that's crazy just for playing
video games
and to me this is a Windows versus doors
thing when the analogy goes like this
most people
only want to work for window on window
opportunities window opportunities where
you could see straight through
you can see what's the value on the
other side and you see what's inside
then you can open up open the window or
break the window whatever hop in and
take the value
what a door opportunity is like a door
is opaque you can't see what's on the
other side you know there's probably
something but you don't see exactly what
it is
and it's good to go for window
opportunities because you can see
exactly what's there but it is bad to be
the type of person who only will do
things and only take massive effort on
window opportunities and you never go
knock on doors and when you knock on
doors it's because uh 90 of other people
have just walked by because they don't
know what's inside they don't they don't
want to make the effort and I think this
is a doors opportunity where people on
Tick Tock are going to get way bigger
than most people realize they're going
to figure out how to make money even in
these like
15 seconds of Fame moments that they're
having and huge brands are going to be
built this way and I just think it's a
door opportunity we haven't we haven't
heard the five success stories you need
to hear before it becomes a gold rush
and everybody starts to copy it that's
true I think though in some regard you
uh like I work in media industry so do
you like it's a pretty like tried and
true method of like getting an audience
and making money through advertising so
I have faith that they'll figure it out
the thing that a lot of these companies
where they screw up there's basically
I've been thinking a lot about this but
there's like one or two mistakes that
you can make and well I mean I've
thought of one or two mistakes that you
can make in business that are like
basically irreversible so most decisions
are reversible not all but most and a
few that are not is if you screw up your
cap table and you raise too much money
and you have a company like BuzzFeed
that makes like 350 million in Revenue
maybe like 50 million in Prof profit I
think their market cap is a hundred and
fifty million right now because
uh like they're like I don't know how
they're gonna you know I don't know how
the markets work like this but they're
never gonna like live up to the hype
that they once had of like 5 billion or
whatever it is same with uh like bird
scooter bird scooter maybe not a
horrible company did you see what their
market cap is today it's like 70 million
or something right what is it no 40. 40
million dollars wow 40 million dollars
and so a company like this like this
house is worth more than bird isn't that
crazy the founder the founder owns house
the founder bought a 20 million dollar
house
isn't that nuts
like the hustle was basically almost
worth more than bird and bird Soul or
raised I think like a billion dollars
right
to be fair the hustle was way cooler
than bird
I mean hey dude scooters littered all
over the city like I [__] with that you
know I I like riding a scooter oh nice
we got your socks on but the the point
being with this with this person's
business they could I think they could
kill it as long as they don't raise too
much money because if they do then I
think that they're gonna they're gonna
die and it's gonna be horrible did I
ever tell you the story about Elizabeth
Murdoch calling me no what was it so the
week the hustle launched I wrote this
blog post saying that we launched and I
get a call a cough and it was this
Australian lady she goes hi this is
Elizabeth Murdock and I knew right away
who that was but I was like wait like
Rupert's daughter like the owner of Fox
Liz yeah I was like Liz what's what's up
what are you doing Colleen she goes hey
I saw your blog post and I think what
you're doing is really cool I uh I think
she said either she's launching or she
already launched this company called uh
I think it was called vertical networks
and it was exactly this thing where she
goes uh basically I negotiated a deal
with Snapchat and uh they asked me to
make content for them so I'm funding
people to make content and you seem kind
of like a loose canon who's pretty funny
uh can I like I don't remember I don't
want to put words in her mouth but she
was like can I buy you or like fund you
and you just make content for us on
Snapchat and I was like huh that's
interesting so I get in touch with like
the guy running the company his name's
Tom he's awesome and he was like Yeah so
basically just like move here and just
start making content all day for
Snapchat and I was like I don't know man
that seems like a lot of work I don't
really want to do that I've got a
girlfriend who I'm probably gonna get
married to and he goes all right well no
big deal we'll find someone else and so
they find someone else and it's a uh
these four guys or three guys and they
started a YouTube channel and a snap or
a Snapchat Channel and then a YouTube
channel and it's called yes Theory have
you heard of yes Theory oh no way that's
that came from that yeah isn't that
crazy so yes theory is this it's like
three guys and their whole idea is like
they do crazy [__] where they like and
these guys are like they're they're my
age but at the time when they started
they were like 25 and 26 so like these
young like good looking dudes and they
would meet someone on the streets of
Venice this like cute girl and be like
hey do you want to go to Rome right now
or they would get they would get in an
Uber and they're like hey Uber driver
um do you want to go to Hawaii this
second we'll go and just leave your car
then we'll just pay for everything and
they do these crazy things like this and
it's this great show and it started
this way as as one of these Snapchat
shows and so what these young women are
doing with this like with this Media
Company it's the same thing that like
has worked before in the past
yeah that's that's really cool I didn't
know uh I didn't know you did that wow
you were so close to a whole different
life
I don't regret it man those guys like
have if you follow their story dude they
get burnt out like because they would do
this crazy stuff at first it was like
let's go skydiving or let's make a
bucket list and do it and then it was
like let's go to the most remote place
on Earth for 24 hours and then let's go
live on an island with people who have
never seen white people why is it that
you always hear about YouTubers getting
burnt out but you never hear podcasters
really getting burnt out because we
don't do [__] we just sit here and talk
like we don't have to do anything like
dude my friend Noah Kagan has this
YouTube channel where he has to go and
like among many things he like knocks on
doors and asks people how they got rich
dude I don't even if I don't see Corn
Flakes at the grocery store I don't buy
it I'm too embarrassed to ask the clerk
at the counter where they are like if
it's not on Amazon or easily available
at a corner store I don't buy it like I
can't imagine knocking on a door and
asking them how they got rich it's hard
it's exhausting especially like Noah's
cool he's he's a friend of ours but
isn't it kind of like no you're above
this like you're Noah you're rich we
should be knocking on your door and
asking you how you got rich this is the
point of being rich that you don't have
to do this [__] yeah but he's you
know broke boys he's trying to play the
game he's trying to get popular I don't
know he's just trying to get popular and
so it's working and he actually has this
new series where he interviews old
people and who are rich and asks him if
it was worth it and that's actually a
very very cool series that one that
one's cooler it's also more like a
podcast it's yes but yeah dude youtubing
is just it seems too hard of a job
so anyway yeah I'm about what these
young women are doing but uh before you
move are you ready to move on to the
next one yeah let's go to something else
wait but before you do I have to I want
to say something to our listeners I'm
gonna say this every episode now until
we hit like 500 000 subscribers I want
to present a a gentleman's agreement do
you know what a gentleman's agreement is
Sean
I was born under a gentleman's agreement
I could a gentleman's agreement I don't
know what that means actually I actually
don't know what it means
it's a non-papered contracted agreement
so people tell us all the time that they
get addicted and they get obsessed with
this podcast that is awesome and so it
doesn't matter if you're on YouTube if
you're on Spotify or you're on iTunes
whatever you're using right now if this
is our your the first episode you're
listening to you get this one for free
but if it's the second episode or more
that you've listened to here's our
Gentleman's Agreement you go to your
YouTube app or whatever you're on and
you click subscribe or follow or
whatever it is and you do that for us we
make this for you we're your like little
research laboratory rats we're doing all
this crap for you just go and do that
for us because the more you do that the
more views we're gonna get the more
hyped we get the more dopamine we get
and the harder we work so that's our
gentleman's agreement if this is your
second plus episode just go and do that
for us right now that's that's my
gentleman's agreement and and the goal
is you said 500 1000 what YouTube
subscribers I think we should just say
500 I think we should just say 500 000
YouTube subscribers we've gone from 20
000 to 150 000 in the last year
150 to 500 this year 2023. all right
down 500 also where's our plaque
I don't know dude I want the platform
like where is the plaque oh you know
we've been talking about participation
trophies like it's a bad thing I want it
I want that yeah
yeah
you say 80 of success is just showing up
what I showed up where's my plan yeah
we were supposed to get a flag at a
hundred thousand you got sent to the
HubSpot headquarters somewhere darmesh
is sitting there polishing our plaque
showing it off at his parties like it's
his where is the plaque I need to know
there's a conspiracy and I need to know
and I told I told the people on Twitter
because I said hey who should keep the
plaque me Sam how are we gonna do this
we're remote it's only one plaque they
said they'll give you a bunch of them
and then people said small boy stuff
you're worrying about a hundred thousand
dollar a hundred thousand subscriber
plaque and I said you know what you're
right we're gonna take the plaque we're
gonna take it to a field and we're gonna
destroy it because it's totally small
boy plaque we're not we're not
celebrating until we're at a million
um but we need the plaque to destroy it
office based style like that is the yeah
I have no problem destroying your plaque
yeah you frame yours
my point is this is our gentleman's
agreement and I'm gonna I'm gonna bring
up our agreement every single time we do
a pod so that's it that's all I gotta
say we can go to the next segment I do
think you totally misused gentleman
agreement but whatever it's uh that's
the best okay what um you had a thing
about
uh coffee Zilla and also can we talk
two after things happened after our
previous episodes number one Tim Ferriss
tweeted out our podcast cool moment Tim
first maybe what was one of the first
podcasts I ever listened to love that
guy he listened to our section where
we're talking about him and my
experience meeting him and all that your
experience meeting him and he said first
he emailed me just goes hey heard heard
the Pod loved it it was so funny Sam was
talking about how OCD I am about editing
things he goes normally I am but you
edited a great thumbs up don't worry
about it and I was like okay good uh and
then by the way I hope I was I hope he
didn't take that as disrespect it was
supposed to be a compliment yeah an
admirable thing Tim ignore the words we
say we're sucking up to you all right
whatever we say we might make some
footfalls on that but we just badly want
to be your friend all right that's just
all that's that's all that you need to
take away from any of this
um all right second thing we did this
episode with Billy McFarland the guy
from fire festival and I think you like
hit him up and hung out with him
afterwards is this true yeah he on the
Pod or either like before after I forget
I told him where I'm basically visiting
family right now and he said oh yeah I'm
right down the street from you
and so I texted him and I just said
thanks for coming on yeah like I'm we're
I'm down the street from you and and he
said great you want to go hang out right
now I go yeah sure let's just go we'll
go get some ice cream what'd you guys do
we went and got we got tea because it
was past 3 P.M and I didn't want to
drink coffee by the way so I got that is
the move don't do coffees anymore ice
cream
just take people out to ice cream
it's an amazing move
they want to lick a thing in front of
them I think that's weird right you
gotta get the spoon yeah
and so we went and hung out and we
talked about like I I can't talk about
it all but we talked about like his
family I just wanted to ask him I was
like tell me about how you were raised
like tell me about your family so I
won't mention that stuff but we talked
about family stuff uh and then we talked
about like uh prison stories
um which she like mentioned on the Pod a
little bit and then I basically told him
what I said here which was this idea
that you had on the pod that's really
stupid man I bet you you could charge
startups twenty thousand dollars a month
and be like a consultant just do that
and he goes yeah let's talk about that
and so we talked about that about like
what we would do if if we were in his
situation and what I think he should do
and uh I talked about
um
the mistakes he made and like why did
you why what were you thinking and he
basically expanded on what we talked
about in the Pod which was like I just
didn't want to look stupid and I lied
and I was embarrassed and I just got
into this you know I just did something
bad but uh yeah hung out with them and
here's my takeaway
I understand why people believed him
very believable very Charming
um like every time he did take you to
ice cream after all dude yeah like I got
whined and done and I could honestly see
myself becoming friends with him but at
the same time I'm like
are you doing it again uh so you know
and that's what I told him I was like
it's hard I think he was I think he was
entertaining enough and I think he
seemed fun like why not be friends with
them and hey even if he does it again
it's as my [__] up friend man
everybody's got a [__] up friend who
just keeps [__] up
he might be yours it's okay if that's
the worst case scenario let's say he's
the worst case scenario
he kind of you know steps in in poo poo
again makes makes the bad decision let's
say that's the worst case scenario
that's all right no no no sweat I feel
like you're a little scared to just be
friends with this guy just be friends
with him dude
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
I'll be friends with them I won't do any
business with them for a long time until
like we've you know he's proven to hang
out with them in public together Are you
ashamed I already did I already did no I
hung out with them in public no and if
someone if I was if I was with him and
someone said something mean to him I
would be like dude you gotta don't do
that right now please let's say that
about my friend Billy yeah don't say
about my friend Billy because here's the
deal that's what I'm talking about dude
he served his time so uh I've like a
volunteered I'm a saint by the way I
volunteered at prisons before so like
I'm a real Saint uh I've like worked
with these types of people before
everyone gets gets a second chance and
man five years or how much did he serve
four years that's a long [__] time
that is a long time that is college
except like you don't leave your dorm
room ever you know like it's the worst
and uh you know I think he paid the
price so I it was really exciting to to
kind of hang out with him what did you
think about the Pod with them yeah I
thought it was good uh I thought he was
you know likable and I thought he was
interesting and I all the same things
you thought I thought he was like about
that he's interesting uh you know I
thought he's you know owned up to what
he did and he didn't try to deny it or
deflect it or give some BS excuses he
was just like yeah I messed up I did it
and I think that most people
who lie don't lie because they're evil
they lie because they're insecure
and they lie because they're afraid I
know this because anytime I lie is
because I'm insecure or afraid and um
and so you know I don't really
like I think that's a completely
understandable thing and I think he did
it at a scale which was bad obviously
that affected people that was bad uh but
also you know put it into perspective
you know like
what did he do he lied to professional
investors who you know in their
diligence didn't uncover it they're fine
you know no harm done for them there
were some people that went to this uh
Festival that got disappointed that's
you know unfortunate but you know okay
but it was a bad really bad party and
then I think the worst thing was like
the locals of the island I think were
sort of left holding the bag in some way
I don't know the full details of that
but I would say that's probably the most
kind of harm done from it and I don't
think that was his intention at all
right I think his intention was to try
to pull this thing off and he he uh
tried to fake it till you make it and he
faked it and didn't make it and like
this is what happens when you fake it
didn't make it right so like I think
that he
rightfully got convicted I think he
served his time and I don't hold that
against him uh go forward I was just
giving you a hard time because I feel
like you like the guy but you're trying
to like
slightly tiptoe a bit around it and I
think you're honestly
and he's fine and you know like let's
let's move on with life and see what he
does from here
that is my honest feeling I like him and
I'm eager to see what he does but I'm
still like I'm still arms like but
here's here's what the fascinating thing
that I hung out with him
I call it like the resistance so I've
said this before the world wants us to
be vanilla they want us to put put us in
his box and people who residated where
are you going with this people who
resist that I'm fascinated by them even
if they are truly a saint or if they're
a criminal there is like this Allure
this Fascination that I have with them
no matter what and I think we all do we
all like that you know people who are
like this is why cult leaders are
awesome you're like oh my God you're
convincing me that there's like another
way of living and and he has that same
thing and there's levels to this is what
I'm learning and his level of like
he he kept telling me he was like I
thought I could pull it off and in my
head I'm like you're [__] insane
everything every little bit of of
evidence points to you not being able to
pull this off but there's something
about you that you think that you could
pull this off even when all the odds are
against you
and you're delusional you still believe
it and there's something incredibly
fascinating about this and it's so
interesting that that he raised 25
million dollars for a festival
when he was 25 years old and he was just
like yeah this is what we're gonna do I
only look forward he was I think he said
on the potty goes I only look forward to
like what's gonna happen uh and I like I
was like that's fascinating to me
because that is not what we are we're
we're we're we're bullied into this box
and anyone who resists that I think is
interesting to me
I think you are you've touched on
something very very true I used to say
this all the time I go I feel like the
world is Baskin Robbins but all 31
flavors are vanilla
and I was just because I was like I look
around and it's all vanilla vanilla over
here another vanilla Choice over there
another vanilla Choice over there
every's living these very vanilla
lifestyles
and I'm not going to pretend I'm some
Renaissance Man adventurous but in my
own way
I feel like I fight the good fight
against vanilla I try to choose to live
my life in a way that makes sense to me
even if it is non-standard
um and that has and that is something
like deep inside deep inside the core I
feel that I feel that that's what I'm
meant to do that's how I'm meant to live
and I take great pride anytime I do
something non-vanilla I try not to do it
just for non-vanilla sake but actually
sometimes I do that too just to push it
right like sometimes I just go and I go
eat the you know
caramel ribbons or the the bubble gum
flavor whatever I don't even like it the
bubblegum flavor tastes tastes nasty but
I'll just do it just to remember remind
myself not to be totally vanilla and so
I am with you on that and that brings me
to something that you tweeted out that I
wanted to talk about it's called The
Adventurous this is a how sick is that
you tweeted something out about this you
go this did you say I don't know what
you say this looks awesome I want to do
it I go to the website
immediately I'm like oh this requires
leaving the house not gonna do it but
let's just check out what other people
are doing copywriting is so good the
copywriting is right I'm just going to
read it out loud because I think it is
worthy of of a little oral speech here
so we're The Adventurous this is what it
says on the website we're fighting to
make the world less boring our planet
used to slap us about the face cheeks
with iron fists of Adventure every day
Maps had edges to walk off whole
continents lay undiscovered but now the
entire surface of the Earth has been
scanned by satellites and shoveled into
your mobile phone tagged with twattery
about what restaurant serves the best
mocha latte frappa [__] we live to find
ways to make the world a bit more
difficult to bring chaos into our over
sanitized lives to create Adventures
where you don't know what will happen
tomorrow or even if you'll make it
because we think there's no greater
moment than those seconds as you leap
into an abyss of uncertainty and
potential disaster
okay so this is our art
fellow artists out there you remember
the episode where Sam declared that he's
an artist has got to create [__] this is
this is really amazing copywriting I
think this is like such a good example
for the swipe file of a I like you know
in my power writing course I'm gonna
like use this as one of the examples of
an US versus them uh us first them frame
status quo breaker which says the status
quo
if they took something good which was
that wow your mobile phone has you know
like the full map and you can get
directions you can find the best
restaurants you can and they're like you
coddled little baby you are you living
this over sanitized life don't you
remember what you were put on this Earth
to do and how life used to be back in
the good old days and I think that that
Nostalgia the US versus them this is
amazing copywriting are you gonna
actually do one of their things yeah I
messaged them and I and I said like uh I
was like hey I'm gonna try and brag to
you because I want to impress you but
here's who I am and I like listed off a
bunch of credentials I go I'm not asking
for a discount also a great copy how do
you how do you brag without how do you
brag while nodding at like I know what
I'm doing here I know why I'm doing this
I just want to say this out loud
likeable bro yeah I emailed them I go uh
well I'm gonna list a bunch of
accomplishments because I want you to
know who I am I'm not exactly a somebody
but I'm not exactly not a somebody uh
here's what I've done and I and I listed
it out and I go the reason I'm
explaining this is I'm gonna pay full
price I'm not asking for any type of
discount or anything like that but like
I want to do one of the America one and
I want to baby like bring a bunch of
friends and like tweet about it and
things like that like when are you doing
in America one because they don't
basically what this company does is you
pay
nineteen hundred dollars or something
like that it's pretty cheap
and then they either give you a car or a
motorcycle or maybe a bicycle for
different races and they host these
races like in Mongolia and they drop you
off at Point a and then it's like you
have three days to travel 300 miles to
point B and they literally just say all
right everyone
bye we'll meet you at point B figure it
out and like one of those things is like
you have to drive a mini bike which is
like a 50cc that which is a very small
motorcycle it's basically what they
wrote on Dumb and Dumber another one is
uh like a car that is a rickshaw which
is like a
well you know what direction does yeah
yeah and so like they do these crazy
things and yeah they're amazing and Sean
go to their FAQs for the event this is
another like really good
um
a really good way to like explain how to
do copywriting because they're FAQs
they're discussing go to like click one
of their random races and then go to
like the FAQs they're discussing really
serious topics in an incredibly
conversational way so they'll say like
they'll say like um we plan on doing
this unless kobit ruins it then it just
ruins it like they just like talk in a
really here's an example I clicked
Mongolia and it says the route uh the
section one the route Mongolia is big
really effing big and driving through it
as any of you ex Mongol rallies know is
brain squashingly awesome thousands of
miles of endless Horizons mountains dirt
roads Nomads blah blah
so riding through it on a motorbike
designed for children is simply
resplendent I don't know what that means
uh Mongolia calls to the soul like a
flight [__] and then it sort of explains
what's going on
and then go to like go to FAQs and
you'll see like they're like you pay
1900 with that comes your little mini
bike some of which are good some are bad
but that's part of the excitement and
then like like they uh and they just
like explained this like what will I eat
mutton noodles question mark whatever
you bring with you buy on the route or
are lucky to be offered lucky enough to
be offered along the way period next
question yes how good is that
foreign
yeah this is really cool who's behind
this is this like uh just a guy I think
it's just two guys like two friends like
these like I I watch their videos they
make launch videos for each one and just
two guys uh
it's really fascinating so I want to do
one I don't want to travel to Mongolia
because like by the time they have it
maybe I'll have like a kid or something
I don't know but like I would like to
like like if they were like if I could
go to Colorado or Canada or like Mexico
I would do it we're more like a
convenient adventurist
yeah yeah so like all the wild in my
backyard yeah so if they could do that
uh speaking of like levels and like
content have you seen coffee Zilla
I've seen coffee Zilla yes can we talk
about this yeah let's talk about it let
me give you the background about this
guy so his name's coffee Zilla he only
has one point something million
subscribers on YouTube so he's not huge
huge yet but he's growing quickly and
yeah small boy stuff he um
and he uh basically his whole thing is
he wants to uncover internet scams
um not just internet but mostly internet
so guys like um
uh fellow podcast guests uh Tai Lopez
like he'll do a whole thing with Ty
Lopez or he'll do a whole thing on
Andrew Tate or whole thing on
Dan Lok who's like another internet guy
which are like typical
question that I often Google which is is
X person legit
exactly and he's trying to answer that
question and usually he's going in
saying they're not legit here's here's
what we know so he's playing this with
you know a bunch of people and now he's
doing on Logan Paul Logan Paul had a
thing called the crypto zoo I think it
was called which was like this crypto
project that had all this [__] going on
but the point being
he has the most attention to detail [__]
I've ever seen like I I saw this on
Casey neistat Casey neistat I'm like how
are you making just your commute to work
so fascinating it was like because he
had all these interesting shots that
were so thoughtful this guy has the same
thing where there'll be like a robot
sitting behind a bar and it's just like
you know like oh I had a tough day at
work coffee still is talking to like a
fake robot and I'm like how is this
interaction so freaking good or he'll
like fly in people who worked with Logan
Paul and he'll interview them in person
and make this whole like 30 minute video
that's as good as 60 minutes and it's so
fascinating and it just shows you that
there's levels to like the game and
people who turn it up a notch I think
they're rewarded yeah this guy uh his
production quality has gotten like kind
of insane
um recently and I think that you know
he's thriving on some of the big you
know questions or controversies SBF uh
Logan Paul who else does he do
um Jake Paul I think he did uh what's
his name
uh entertain things and things like that
uh yeah he's he's cool he's he's good
and I I really like this Niche like I
think he's carved out like a really
strong Niche
um and brand like visual brand too so I
think he's done a kind of an amazing job
with with his videos and his content but
he kind of has pigeon told himself and
there's this one move that a lot of
people make the liver King made it when
he said I do not take steroids and now
this guy is he does the same thing where
he says I do not make money through
advertising through ads because I want
you the reader or the viewer to be
supporting me so I can make more genuine
[__] and I'm like no don't shut that off
you may feel that way you may feel that
way today but like Casey neistat has
this funny thing where he was like dude
I had 100 million views before I turned
ads on my YouTube because I thought I
was being like an artist and that was
the stupidest thing ever because like I
had I was so broke at the time and I
couldn't like make more videos and had I
done that I would have made an
additional million dollars or whatever
it is and that's how exactly how I feel
I'd like to just take the money you
could take the money and still be cool
and ethical and by the way we could put
like a before and after on the screen
like if you go back into his channel
three years ago it's literally him in a
messy bedroom he's like holding a mic up
with his hand and you know he literally
looks different his background looks
different and that's like you know how
he started and this you can see the jump
up and quality in three years is like
pretty insane to be honest with you
three years isn't that long dude it this
podcast is three years old I think and
like just like the other day you like
didn't even wear a shirt when you
recorded like like a potential Choice
like we we still don't I don't even have
a camera that works yet I mean like like
this guy this guy basketball hoop behind
me now so we're moving up like it took
forever just to get a video camera that
works and we still call it a video
camera uh like
yeah I asked how to get a camcorder uh
yeah his per his progress is is
wonderful yeah that's amazing um all
right what else we got what other what
other uh content you want to do
I don't have anything okay wow the well
the well-runath drive uh okay let me
give you one
um have you seen this website gently.com
no I think this is kind of a cool idea
basically it's you know like people you
do this probably you probably buy like
kind of vintage leather goods or
whatever off of like I don't know
whatever some like eBay or Poshmark or
depop there's all these second hand
marketplaces that that exist so I just
named three or four of them uh the real
real right there's like all these
different places you could go what
gently did was pretty smart was they
just said all right how do we make a
search engine so you just tell us what
product you want we will go search all
the different places and then we will
just send you text message alerts as we
find good deals on that thing here and
that brand or that item that you want I
think this is pretty smart and then they
cut a deal with all the different
Marketplace which is hey if we send you
the customer we bought we get to bring
the customer the buyer to you how do we
get you know our 10 kit cut or whatever
it is off of that purchase I think this
is anytime you have like a fragmented
set of places where something is the
One-Stop search for it and search and
look they did smart there's like these
alerts so
uh as soon as you put in that you're
interested in something they'll just
constantly alert you about this thing
it's sort of like this like highly
targeted you know ad that they're
sending you each time and then you can
go and you can buy the thing and I think
this is pretty cool saves the customer a
bunch of time brings these marketplaces
customers and um and does it in a way
that's like actually like pretty
seamless I thought this is actually a
pretty cool idea I'm gonna sign up for
this uh you are right you stereotype to
me correctly you made some pulled you
you made a stereotype and uh you're 100
correct uh I was looking at investing in
it and I was like all right let me just
try using this thing and I was like oh I
don't have like Hobbies or tastes like
you know there's not a I don't know any
of these Brands I don't buy any vintage
Goods or like you know exclusive
designer things and so didn't really
know what to do well it looks like it's
you're trying it looks like if it's good
well it looks like it's for women mostly
um because it's Poshmark that's mostly
women I think only women or mostly women
the real real Mostly women I actually
just went to the real real yesterday
they have a story where I'm staying uh
it's mostly women I I believe but no I I
like this I don't know if this could be
a big business wouldn't the margins be
like nothing yeah because you're taking
a cut of a cut so I think that's the the
hard part you have to have like really
high volume
um
but I do think there's an it's a it's
enough of an interesting wedge where
like they'll probably need a second
Miracle meaning if they'd have to the
first miracle is getting this popular
where people start using this all the
time and then the second Miracle is
going to be something like you know they
they create their own you know Supply on
the on the marketplace or they create
their own Marketplace out of this or
they got to do something maybe it's a
subscription I don't know they'd have to
come up with some other thing that's
going to um
gonna make this work so so I do think
that that's the that's the second thing
all right let me give you an idea now
um
you've used click funnels correct
yeah I have I've made a lot of money
using click funnels if I ask you what is
Click funnels great at why would anybody
use click funnels
quickly spin Up drag and drop landing
pages that can also accept money
and the landing page well there's a
bunch of landing page builders that are
drag and drop why click funnels is it
better design is it you know
faster easier to use what is the benefit
it's mostly horribly designed uh it
looks like it was designed with like a
set of crayons and the reason it's like
a perfect way to say it yeah it looks
like someone like just got like a red
and blue crayon and like whiteboard it
they just like turn that into a website
uh
so no uh it does it just has a three or
four features that are exactly what you
need for getting money quickly on a
website and I think you know one of them
the way I would describe it is called
click funnels for a reason which is that
they are they're specifically funnels so
they're like designed to convert a
customer
um through a funnel which the funnel
might happen it might be like first
we're going to grab their email we're
gonna optimize for grab email then once
they grab the email we're gonna then
offer them this upsell and we're gonna
then ask them to pay and if they don't
pay then then they'll go here the whole
point of their software is to get your
money to become my money and
that's like what they do they go you
have someone on your website how do you
get the money in their Bank their bank
account into yours and they make it easy
so you think I'm like perfect you can
exam
you accept an email you get the sale you
do it upside out you do all this stuff
and they're unabashed they they're
unashamed whereas
upsell it'll be like upsell one then if
they say yes hit them with upsell two if
they say yes hit them with upsell three
if they say no hit them with down sell
down sell one down cell two down it's
like what the hell are they I literally
don't even have enough products to like
fill your funnel I don't have down sell
products what are these
um but it works it works it was quite it
works and I think clickfunnels does over
100 million in revenue or something like
that they throw that 100 million number
around a lot I think it's way more than
a time or an annual thing I think
they're churn is really high that's
that's the problem with these things is
like the churn like that attitude of
like make your bank account my bank
account that all doesn't exactly have
the most like the best longevity but
yeah your customers are kind of piece of
[__] marketers
you're like bullying them yeah I think
so I think somebody can make
a click funnels 2.0
um in fact I think we could make click
funnels 2.0 uh like I think if we used
our brand we could create a better click
funnels which is what the guy did
Russell Brunson he had a uh he was like
a Content guy I mean he he like had
masterminds and [__] like that but he
had like a huge email list and then he
like launched the software and it wasn't
great at first in fact it's still not
really that great if there are any
developers or designers that don't use
crayons
um you know build us a click funnels
competitor We Will We Will promote it
because Cleveland is honestly a very
useful tool it is super useful good at
doing the job which is the your money to
my money thing which is exactly what a
lot of people want and it's simple and
that's the beauty of it when you make a
click funnels page it's like there's no
navigation there's no footer there's no
scroll it's like yeah it's a giant box
that says give me your [__] email and
it says it's like a flashing button and
it says if you click this thing with
your email something good is gonna
happen and like they'll might be
something good I guess I'll put my email
in and for some reason I don't know why
this is still a thing when you sell a
product there all of the product images
are like pictures of DVD and PC game
boxes do you know what I mean it's a box
set always it's like a CD
dude like I don't even own a thing that
could accept a CD why is like this this
like product always like a set of CDs
yeah
looks like this because it's infomercial
right it's the equivalent of an
infomercial but online
um so I think some somebody click
funnels I also think specifically for
e-commerce there's not really a click
funnels for e-commerce there's a bunch
of people who think they're you click
funnels for e-commerce and trust me I am
in e-commerce I have tried to build
funnels using Shogun Builder all of
these guys
nobody's done it nobody has made it
simple nobody has made it stupidly
obvious where you hit the customer over
the head with the offer and like that's
all you really need to do and I've
looked at so many of these and nobody
has nobody's made it dumb enough
everybody makes it too smart and um and
so I think there's there's generally
like a click funnels like 2.0 and I
think that there's click funnels for
e-commerce is a is an opportunity that's
out there and I think you would need
like you'd either need to be a Russell
Brunson type of guy where you are going
to independently build your brand as a
smart content entrepreneur marketer type
dude or you should partner with uh or
like you know we like someone like us
who already has that audience and that
brand can distribute a product like this
and get it to
I don't know probably somewhere between
like three and six million AR just off
of our audience um it's hard it's
actually good but the product actually
has to be good have you heard of uh well
so another thing that click funnels did
like these guys are really fascinating
and at first I was a hater on them and
then I was like oh no they're all right
uh but they they
they're what their conferences are are a
little cringe but still cool like I
respect it but they make money off info
products and this was so fascinating and
so smart so a lot of big software
companies they're like dude I'm not
gonna sell anything but the software
because like this one thing makes so
much profit and revenue like I'm just
doing this one thing and they were like
nah F that see we don't have a lot of
money to spend so we're bootstrapped our
marketing is going to be profitable and
so they write like guides and do all
this stuff and they'll charge like a
hundred dollars for like a book and when
you buy that book you're automatically
like get a you know a month free of
Click funnels and they basically when
they hit 100 million in Revenue it was
80 million in subscription revenue and
20 million in info product revenue and
they would create these info products
and sell it and that's good because
they would acquire a customer for a
break-even amount for an info product
and automatically add them into their
subscription revenue for their software
and that was really fascinating I
thought it was a great idea and they've
proven that it can work really nicely
yeah I think in general uh Break Even
marketing is a phrase I've used in every
every single company I've built which is
like what is a version of our marketing
that itself is a not a cost center as a
profit Center it doesn't have to be the
main marketing channel
but like we should do something like for
you hustlecon was a good example of this
right it's like yeah I'm gonna do
hustlecon it's going to get people to
find out about the hustle it's going to
take people who like us and make them
love us and make them super evangelists
and it's going to get all these speakers
to come speak that'll become content so
that's marketing there
but you were like yeah but this is not
just like a money pit no we need to make
money on our marketing and I just feel
like most people don't really consider
that but it like at twitchcon when I was
at twitch it's the same thing twitch
there's this thing called twitchcon it's
this like I don't know 30 40 50 000
people something show up to this thing
it's all did they make money off that
and they they don't really try to make
money off of it but the merch store at
twitchcon literally the line is like
it's like imagine like the San Diego
Conference Center or whatever which is
like a you know a three mile long
building or some [__] like that the line
is the entire three miles it's like the
craziest line you've ever seen people
waiting slowly like hours to go in to
buy your hoodie
and I was like this is crazy how much
are we making off this and like it was
like you know run by this like
two-person team it wasn't really like
the main focus and like you know the
event itself you know has sponsor stuff
and they did have Revenue but like
I felt like there could be so much more
that was done there was so much more
like potential to commercialize that
thing and I get it which is like in your
company of twitch's size you don't need
to worry about making a couple million
bucks off this thing but if you shrink
that it kills me it still kills me yeah
exactly exactly it's like well first of
all you should have just been able to
sell more merch just like by being more
efficient like you know how many people
didn't wait in this four hour line uh
you know that that's just like one thing
all together the second thing is
um if you're not twitch you're not
generating you know
call it billion dollars of Revenue uh if
you're click funnels or the hustle or
you're a normal size business
these these break-even marketing things
a marketing event that makes you 500k or
1.5 million or something like that
that's actually quite meaningful
um compared to it losing 500k or losing
a million dollars which is where most
companies default to and I think just
with a little bit of creativity you
could turn a lot of cost centers into
profit centers or at least Break Even
when it comes to marketing dude there's
this attitude that I've been having
lately so I've been working on this like
new project and I've switched my
attitude when I was starting the hustle
I was like um I'll do anything for any
Advertiser to make any amount of money
like whatever dude you know what I mean
like I'm like whatever I just need I
need pennies give me pennies I'll do it
all and I'm like yeah sure like you know
you know the rules said no CBD but like
you know like what's I have an eraser we
can erase that rule and uh
now I've been like saying like nope this
is what it is I say no to everything and
like oh this person wants to join I
don't really feel like it let's just
raise the price really high so they
don't want to join or like you know what
I mean or like like let's like this this
type of attitude
it's made it's made the businesses so
much more successful having that
attitude and like it's it's pretty funny
you know like there's this hot girl that
I knew and I was like and she was like
joking and she was like my motto for
getting dudes is uh treat them mean keep
them Keen the meaner I treat them the
happier the more they want me and I was
like that's the greatest thing ever I'm
gonna do that with my life of course it
didn't work with women but uh it's kind
of worked with business this tree to
mean keep them Keen it's like the more
we say no the more they want it and I
can't believe it's worked that way
dude rhyming is just an underrated
strategy in general let me just put that
out there I don't know what the hell
she's talking about but it rhymed and
that made me feel good made me think
that she's got her [__] together dude
treat them mean keep them Keen you lived
in Australia Akin means like you know
like you like them yeah you shouldn't
need a dictionary for your catchphrases
I I that's my personal opinion
um right like you didn't know who Dolly
Parton was though so like you don't
really know anything
[Laughter]
all right um I got a bone to pick with
the fitness industry so
you're fit I'm aspiring to be fit yeah
and a lot of the products I feel are
geared towards people like you it's like
bro you want to be ripped it's hey do
you want you know girls do you want a
bigger butt and flatter stomach you know
that's kind of like me
that's you and then that's the female
version of you
um
I feel like 90 of like ad dollars go
towards that when it comes to Fitness
would you say that's true
yeah just people who want to look good
naked so you're struggling with your
light bulb there by the way I know see
there's this thing there's this compass
that lets you show how to center it
perfectly so that it uh floats
but it's not not participating people
are loving that thing by the way you're
gonna sell a lot of them in the videos
they're loving that light bulb yeah I
know I'm not shouting out who made this
because I'm gonna make our own this is
this is the start of our merch store
I've decided we need to do merch
um
we're two we're too [__] catchy to
not have merch
bro we just gotta get the coin business
um coins dollar bills whatever all right
so so anyways Fitness okay 90 of dollars
I feel like go towards getting you
spring break ready but
uh my trainer for example he works out
he works me out in the garage and in
doing so there's a whole bunch of people
that pass by and I gotta say the most
interested group of people that pass by
are not looking to get ripped shredded
jacked swole whatever words you want to
say those aren't the words that they're
interested in they want to be knee
pain-free they want to be back pain free
they want to be foot pain free and I
feel like the
pain-free uh version of exercise is a
little under marketed and for every you
know P90X or Beachbody program
I think that there should be
a even bigger version of that that's
just helping Mom not have knee pain when
she walks or gets up from her chair and
um and I think that what happens is
there's a lot of workout programs that
would say we could do that that's what
ours our program is great for that like
we both like these over toes guy he's
great for that but there's still this
leap that the person has to put together
that oh if I do these exercises then
that will be the the benefit that I get
out of it whereas somebody else might be
trying to jump higher run faster and I
think that in the same way that the uh
you know that vitamin brand Ollie how
they instead of saying we provide
vitamin D uh or we we provide magnesium
it's like it's like we better sleep
better yeah yeah immunity sleep better
you know whatever they basically just go
straight to the benefit and I think that
there should be a juggernaut of a
fitness company that is simply trying to
make it so that you are back pain and
knee pain and foot pain free neck pain
these are common pains that people who
are you know know have a ton of money
have a ton of motivation to get these
things fixed and it's just a lightweight
exercise program I've been telling you
about this remember I was like my
Instagram feed is just full of shirtless
dudes like stretching their hips and
like doing like stretches like it's just
this whole they call it Mobility now
Mobility is the new pain-free you know
or Mobility is like the new yogabilities
I think I think it's the right idea but
I think it's the wrong frame I don't
need shirtless dudes stretching their
hips I need Mom saying
um I woke up every day and I had this
problem I just I just thought it was I'm
getting old that's it and then they put
me on this you know 21 Day program by Dr
knee and Dr knee thank you so much I now
walk pain-free I walk my dog I can play
with my grandkids thank you so much Dr
knees and we need Dr knees as the brand
and we need the testimonial not being
ripped shirtless guy stretching his hips
it needs to be you know
what do they call it the silver tsunami
or whatever like it used to be somebody
with a little gray hair saying how they
used to not be able to just you know do
simple stuff in the kitchen and get out
getting out of bed and now they can
I I mean I don't know what else to say
other than yeah I agree
uh the company
um was it called uh what was the thing
that it's like I I have one is it
hypervolt I forget one of the one of
those like either hypervolt or
therageous they said I remember the
scene their pitch when they raised money
they go we want to be the Nike for
recovery and right I actually don't I
think is the thing is it hyper ice I
think that'd be challenging to pull off
because they're just kind of selling
like a product that's a bit commoditized
now just like this vibrating thing uh
but they've done a pretty good job with
The Branding but I think that that pitch
was quite interesting and I actually
think it has legs I think challenging
but it has legs and I think you could
also have like a Nike for
you know like pain-free like like I
actually do think that that's like there
is something quite interesting there
with that yeah the way calm did around
meditation if someone did around just
getting rid of pains that you think you
have to live with but actually can be
reversed do you have pain
I don't but like like for example my
trainer he trains he trains me but he
also trains my mom he trains my neighbor
who's like the CEO of a big tech company
but then he also trains his mom and in
fact my neighbor who's the CEO of a tech
company he will miss sessions all the
time because like you know whatever he's
on calls and [__] like that
but his mom never misses it and she's
never worked out like she didn't have a
gym membership so she went from 900 gym
membership to having a personal trainer
and would you see what he'd has her do
it's like
is this a library like you're stationary
for like 90 of the workout and it's like
yeah if she's sitting down flat footage
she's just trying to push up from like
you know her toes because her toes are
incredibly weak and that's causing a
whole bunch of structural issues so he
just works toes then ankles then he gets
to the to the calf and the hamstring
then the knee you know and he's just
working his way up rebuilding it and
she's like mowing her lawn now like she
couldn't like walk basically like she
could from my neighbor's house to my
house she basically couldn't get there
each day and now she's literally mowing
her lawn and um and that's like kind of
a kind of kind of a crazy recovery why
don't you just get ripped just do that
also
I'm trying
your boy likes cheese okay there's a
little bit of a problem
so I I'm gonna have to show you a
shirtless pick because oh so I like it
got really strong and then over the past
like eight weeks I've lost 15 pounds and
I'm trying to like I just like to try to
do things so now I'm trying to get
skinny and everyone's like how are you
doing it and the answer is I just don't
really eat you just be hungry all the
time and my trainer my trainer was like
well what's your goal and he I go uh I
want to look good naked and live forever
and uh he was like cool well one of the
proven things that makes that people
live for a long for a long time is
calorie restriction so just not eating a
lot so if you want to live for a long
time you just got to get used to not
eating a lot so I'd be getting used to
it and
it's not so bad it's not so bad but it
is kind of bad it's pretty bad I'm on
that Warren Buffett kick bro I try to
live till 95 Rich happy telling great
stories eating like [__] but enjoying
every every meal as you drink like a
Coke Zero a Coke Zero that's my Splurge
I drink a Coke Zero and I drink a Fresca
that's my drink you ever drink a Fresca
here's another service
someone who has the exact same life
scenario as you but is fit we'll send
you a shirtless picture every day and
say there's no excuses oh you're you're
a mother of three here's the mother of
three who's fit she's gonna send you a
picture every morning what's your excuse
now oh you're an entrepreneur Sam Potter
is gonna send you a picture every day
and say yeah I'm also an entrepreneur
what's your excuse It's Gonna be called
shamefully shamefully
safely.ly shameful Lily yeah and we
simply ask you what's your excuse what
look we started actually like a nice guy
hey we understand life's tough what's
holding you back the realities of life
is your time is it money is it your kids
is it your your unsupportive husband
what is it and then we find you an exact
match who's overcome that that thing and
they just guilt you every morning if
you're on your phone right now listening
to this go to tick tock or maybe also
Instagram but for sure Tick Tock and
type in the word Papa swole so it's
p-a-p-a and then swole
s-w-o-l-l I think or s-w-o-l-e there's
this guy on Tick Tock who came out of
nowhere and he has at this point like
three or four million followers or maybe
even more I forget I looked a few months
ago
and all he does all day is he has one
video and he just walks up to the camera
and he goes go to the [__] gym go to
the [__] gym go to the gym that's all
he says and now he's selling T-shirts
and mugs and all this stuff and he three
times a day he makes the same video
every single day and just says go to the
gym go to the gym and it's hilarious
have you seen this yeah I see this guy
he just walks up to the camera
dramatically and says this one thing and
everyone everyone goes crazy it's the
best let me tell you about a different a
different Tick Tock thing that I think
is pretty dope all right um let's let's
wrap it there I still got some more but
it's there's too late the opposite to
bring him up and bring him up now
um all right
[Music]
foreign